sitting here in studio one of my
favorite guests and people that I've
gotten to meet being a host of this show
the Rockets general manager daryl morey
good to see you sir
thanks again you bet good to see you on
anything been going on with you lately
we have two two MVPs the two of the last
three that that's been a good formula
for teams recently that is that is
absolutely right
okay I'm gonna just get right to it
right off the bat with you gentlemen
it's sort of a this is your life type
game you remember that show this is your
life
all right so let's just start right off
the bat I don't think this is the the
full Dan Patrick show treatment that you
received earlier in the week but let's
get right to it do you recognize this
voice Daryl Morey do you recognize this
voice you said a couple days ago that
Chris Paul is gonna be a Rockette next
season do you yep is that a 100% you can
say that with that certainty right now I
can know who is who was that voice from
five weeks he goes a voice manipulator
like scream was untouched that was
untouched I should know in sports I was
gone I 9.9% say that then that that does
open a door for somebody like me to come
crashing through no no I do I did not
have to admit I did not anticipate
Russell Westbrook to be available like
it's Chris Paul's an amazing player and
we were only gonna ever do anything
unless we're getting something amazing
back and right I didn't that hold
maneuvering I didn't say I should have
seen it maybe but I did not see it
nobody saw Paul George saying I want out
and I'm gonna go tonight I didn't see it
at all he picked them I mean there are
the rumors he was gonna go to LA the
year before but when he signed again in
Oklahoma City I was like oh he must you
must love it there so we did not
anticipate that did I anticipate an MVP
to be available and yeah so I should
have gone with 99.9 right the sort of
Michael Jordan that point oh one percent
of possibly not being retired so when
you heard that Paul George was going to
the Clippers along with Kawhi did that
put a lightbulb over your head about
Russell Westbrook on the spot
not actually just made me say I should
check in and say maybe they're going in
a different direction I still didn't
think they would do something like trade
Russell Westbrook just because he you
know he signed for six years there I
mean he it just didn't seem like someone
they would move still so I did make a
note to check in the next day though cuz
you know that kind of a move
maybe baguettes other moves with other
players on the roster but I thought
they'd still build around Russell and so
when did you reach out to Sam Presti
though the next day next day yeah I mean
if it was later the season might wait a
little bit because you don't want to be
like the ambulance chaser we were
talking about that but but but I would
say in the off season like it's fast and
furious so yeah you got a check-in right
away because you were concerned others
might check in for for us you know
obviously he's a great anytime a great
player is available every team should
check in and I'm sure Sam was sick of
all the calls he got but when you make a
move like that you're gonna get a lot of
calls okay so uh if there was nothing
wrong with Chris Paul and Harden why
would you check in with the Oklahoma
City Thunder well for Russell Westbrook
first off they have good players on
their roster so it's my job to check in
on that and yeah I mean Russell
Westbrook if he's available is something
I've got an investigate yeah if he get
feet were traded to a different team for
something less than what we would give
up it would be a problem right I mean
he's you know to get a recent MVP
I think only four times in NBA history a
team has had two MVPs in the in a
three-year span on the same team and
it's it's always ended in a championship
now obviously we're gonna have to go out
and win it but it's a pretty good
formula when did you first reach Harden
or did he harden first reach you about
this subject daryl morey yeah I talked
to him the next day cuz it the move
happened so late at night it was like I
was stunned I mean honestly it was one
of those things where you know you reach
for your glasses and you're like okay
I'm reading this right right that that
Paul George and Kauai are gonna be
teaming up to go to the Clippers
so you reach you you picked up the phone
and called the Lord I've had a lot of
upset media people are like he didn't
time it well we couldn't prep put a lot
of content together sure right I was
like I don't think I don't think who I
was thinking about you guys but but but
yeah I know I talked to James the next
day and yeah well after I'd spoke to
Oklahoma City and it seemed like there's
there's some chance oh good you know
James has been playing with Russ in LA
since like he's six years old so they
know each other real well so let's let's
get into I've kind of discussed this
with you before and I talked about it
with your colleague in in New Orleans
and David Griffin when he called in the
show is the position of you as a general
manager in the NBA that you could be
just on a cruise in your ship hoping to
get to some sort of championship
destination you like your roster the way
it is you've set it up you've signed a
star long term and then all of a sudden
the stars like I got a call from my
buddy I don't want to play for you
anymore and that's life I mean why can't
a general manager in this league say no
would you we had on track no we have and
and mostly we've been lucky that players
haven't done that so we've been lucky I
think obviously he sends a destination
city that players love playing in we've
had a great winning tradition
second-most wins over the last 15 years
so players you know our coat coat people
love coach Dan Tony love ownership
someone Fertitta so we've not had that
situation but for sure we we've had
trade requests and we've said we've said
ya know you're signed so so you've had
trade requests from your from players on
your current roster no on rosters in the
past saying one out yeah and we've just
said no that's not that's not how it
works now to be fair to David Griffin
and others like each situation is unique
and you got to handle it the right way
but we've we've not had that situation
and then on top of it when it's come up
with
non star players we've we just said look
you know that's not something we're
gonna do well I mean it's interesting
you say non star players because star
players can make life very difficult if
this study cast out and then there's you
know with the advent of Twitter and
Instagram and so many other ways that a
player can get his information or hers
out to the public without having to go
through PR or a release like a video it
can make life very difficult on a front
office is there some sort of movement
afoot to actually codify something to
try and rectify what we've seen from
Paul George and obviously Anthony Davis
think there's any way to do it I mean
I'm very Pro player empowerment that's
been one of our advantages as you even
saw we involve our stars and big
decisions at the end of the day like
these top players are what drives the
league it's what people come to see and
it's very appropriate that they are
involved in everything and I feel like
it's my job to make sure they never want
to leave not worry about how to make it
so they can never do it that's what
David Griffin said like just create a
spot where people are gonna want to play
he also called us a basketball legal
tampering say David's got more clips of
me he's pretty right about that yeah
what would you agree with that
assessment I think well I mean obviously
the top top players all play us a
basketball and they all get together and
yeah and they're they're mad they're
like Game of Thrones they're masters of
the universe where they're sort of
figuring out which which area of the map
to to allocate for them to team up so I
think it's great for the league honestly
people think it's sort of weird and
different looking at history in the past
where players had to fight for years and
years even to get free agency it seems
weird but you know at the end of the day
people come to watch the stars and that
yeah I think it's appropriate that they
have a big big saying where they're
going I'm just thinking a little bit to
which I'm sure you do also but for fans
you know kids sitting there in Oklahoma
City staring into space bummed when
Damian Lillard waved bye bye to them
having no idea that we were all waving
bye-bye to them as they were
constituted and for supposedly for years
to come
you know like any any rockets fan right
now fired up you got it done down where
you did in fact bring Russell Westbrook
to town if Paul and say Hardin we're not
meshing and you got that situated but
what if suddenly Russ turns around and I
want to play with a buddy of mine
sitting here in Los Angeles I mean what
what how does that work you know yeah I
do think it's tough we went through some
tough times between our Yao and Tracey
era and then when James Harden came
where yeah I told people to get a jersey
with their own name on the back because
you know we were doing a lot of changes
because we're trying to get back to
being a championship team so I do think
that's that's probably the biggest
negative angle I've seen and this could
be where people get down is you know a
lot of kids our fans are the players now
so they'll like I know for sure we have
lots of fans in Oklahoma City or Rockets
fans now because they've they're gonna
be excited to watch Russell on on the
Houston Rockets what did what did Hardin
say can you share to you when you said
hey it's the same as whenever I call
about any star of being available which
is quite a few were available in free
agency you know he wants to play with
him he wants to bring him here he wants
to win a title he's hungry to win a
title whatever move we can get to get a
player that'll help us win the title
he's he's all in force and just the fact
that he knows him and he's played real
he knew Russell really really well
obviously played with them in the NBA he
can't be more intimate than that but but
even growing up in LA they've they
played with each other and against each
other where does this feel you you've
been very wide open saying that you were
building your team to try and take down
the Warriors and it looks like the
Warriors are no longer the Warriors that
we've gonna be really good actually
to me there's six really really good
teams in the West and it's pretty even
across if you look at Vegas we're ranked
somewhere between one and three in terms
of title odds and over/under and wins
and I think that's about right but but
there's six teams that are really really
strong I think and it's gonna be a war
and it's gonna be fun mmm where do you
think you stand first yeah 100%
[Laughter]
well done down boy
yeah I mean you gotta obviously speak it
into existence but you do I I mean
you're bringing back you were saying
when you did use the hundred percent for
the first time saying how everybody else
was in flux
everybody else was while there may be
getting stronger in flux that you were
ready to run it back and that you had
that so basically you're just swapping
out Paul for Westbrook and running it
back right and there are different
players but we think Russell in coach
D'Antoni system who I think is one of
the best ever at taking a guy's strength
and utilizing him on the floor doesn't
ask for them to change he he moulds to
them and I think in our structure at
home what mike is gonna want him to do
he's gonna be great okay
and they're still is just one basketball
right I think I mean we are trying to be
innovative here with maybe we'll go
we'll try to how is that gonna work I
mean you know what the fans are saying I
mean harden Lux at his hand and so
Russell's the king of the triple-double
and obviously part of the triple-double
is dishing but when we brought Chris
Paul and everyone said it wasn't gonna
work and this is similar it's it's gonna
work I think if you saw Russell's
opening press conference he was like
we're not even gonna ask him to change
but he was talking about how he needs to
you know go back to what he was doing
when James was on the ball at Oklahoma
City cutting moving you know doing
whatever is necessary to win a few more
minutes left with Daryl Morey Rockets GM
right here live in the rich eyes answer
studio in Los Angeles what what needs to
be changed for the free agency period
cuz it I mean there seemed to be some
highly highly baked deals announced
within mere seconds of the deadline
passing or starting with the windows
supposedly opening up what needs to be
changed why think Commissioner silver is
he's a great leader and he's already on
this which is you know there's a lot of
rules that they have on the books that
are basically unenforceable they're
they're good in concept but
unenforceable so I think you know he's
talking about changing them such that
the ones that they have on the books
they're gonna be very diligent and
enforce and the ones that are almost
impossible to enforce like agents
talking to players
and to sell that kind of stuff that
maybe those will change so we'll see
what Commissioner does but wait what do
you want to see done I've spoken to him
I I think I agree a lot of that stuff
you know he would have come up with this
on his own but stuff I've suggested to
him which is like it hurts the league
office to have unenforceable rules they
should they should be very end to me
like if you can't create an environment
your your players want to be in and they
can choose they want to leave just based
on one phone conversation with somebody
right then that's your problem you're
you haven't created the environment for
that player to want to stay so what
about finals are over confetti is taken
out of everybody's hair day after that
you can start talking to free agents
what about that oh yeah and then and
then you have a draft afterwards you do
the free agency first and the draft just
a lot of things right well I mean look
so much conversation about how NBA free
agency however was far more fascinating
and exciting than NFL free agency
obviously if the NBA had a franchise tag
Kawhi wasn't going anywhere so it's
apples and oranges from that point of
view however it's helpful to know what
you need to draft because you've gone
through free agency first plus it's also
helpful to put the Hat of the team that
the draft II is going to on the head of
the draft II with confidence that that
is the Hat he's going to wear yeah it's
really weird that NBA draft you don't
know who's going where it's so it's very
hard to watch but yeah putting free
agency first I think is I think is
better I also think the reason the NBA
free agency is such a big deal is not
only our players like more out front
public you know you can see them you
know the helmet all the usual arguments
but they also make a way bigger impact
like are the only players who come close
to having even the impact of like your
second-best player on an NBA team is is
the quarterbacks in in the NFL and so
our top few players have such a big
impact you know you just if you want to
decide who's gonna win the title you
don't even have to look at role players
generally you just have to count the
number of like all NBA players they have
and that will that will basically track
how Vegas is projecting that team so
those big players moving creates a lot
of drama and fun would you be fine with
a period of talking with free agents
right away I mean right as soon as the
season I would be it's more realistic
yeah or just always I mean yeah well I
mean that would be that would be
something although I mean player two
player these conversations happen
constantly constantly so like why
pretend it doesn't happen well certainly
if a player now is a part owner or as
associates who are owning agencies
sports agencies I mean that is part of
what's going on with Anthony Davis and
and LeBron and the Lakers at least two
people are supposing that that yeah I
don't think you I think formally having
ties into ownership does create a lot of
conflict so that would be probably
something that should always be not
allowed okay before I let you go couple
more things left with daryl morey help
me out with this who was if you can be
if you know who is the person who came
up with the term load management do you
know I think it's Stan Van Gundy you
know I mean what a way to come up with
the term of we're not playing our star
tonight because he's taken a night off I
mean yeah I don't like the term in fact
I think that was asked about it recently
and I the first thing I said was we
don't label it like to me it's just
common sense logical you're trying to
win the title so we're going to focus on
making sure our player is at their peak
in the playoffs which is a grueling
obviously to get to 16 wins yes and so
to me it's just common sense we don't
need a term for it we're not gonna have
a specific like we're calling it load
management and this will be exactly what
they do but we're gonna have a plan
ahead work with Russell work with James
Hart and work with our other key players
because we are the most veteran team in
the league now and you know have a plan
but we bob and weave like if you win a
bunch of games in a row maybe the
pressure comes off if you lose a bunch
in a row it's not like it does matter
how the season unfolds like you
we'll not when your schedule comes in
your hand say this day you were
definitely on a load management
situation basically what we do is we say
okay here in an ideal world where we're
tracking to 55 to 65 wins an on pace
here's how we think it will probably be
best handled but then how the team
performs how that players injuries map
out there's a lot of how much how much
effort they're expending in certain
practices and games all go into like
managing it through the season and it's
not just before the year we're not gonna
play this game that came this game okay
one's your fantasy football draft you
know I haven't gotten it scheduled you
know how hard those things are to
schedule so commissioner yeah you're
probably Commissioner really it's it's
it's a whole it's a whole job I just say
everyone's got I do that sometimes then
I get a lot of hate and so who's in your
league my wife who beats me yeah just a
bunch of friends from college you know
the usual usual thing what's tip
mortified have any cool celebrities
what's what's more difficult to schedule
then your fantasy draft or James
Harden's load management I would say
just dictate and say hey this is a day
too bad if you can't make it will Auto
draft you in you're screwed by the way
that would be a bad fantasy team lame is
load management that's true I can do
anything so I'm gonna make someone have
that name at de Maury on Twitter at
daryl morey on instagram getting ready
for your 13th season as a GM of the
Houston Rockets good to see you thanks
for letting me know you're in town I
really appreciate you're welcome anytime
that's a Dalmore right here for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 under red TV for free on VR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app